Sponsored by Newport Healthcare, providing results-driven mental health care for teens and young adults ages 12 to 28, who are struggling with trauma, depression, anxiety, and other mood personality and co-occurring disorders. At Newport Healthcare, tailored treatment plans foster sustainable healing to help young people move from struggling to thriving. Learn more at newporthealthcare.com. The last few years have seen an explosion of digital technologies that promise to help people achieve their health and fitness goals. There are apps to track your diet and weight, count your steps, and customize your exercise routine. One 2020 Market Research Report found that the global health and fitness app market is now worth $1.3 billion and predicted it would be worth more than $4 billion by 2030. These apps may be a commercial success, but are they a useful public health tool?
本期节目由 Newport Healthcare 赞助，为 12 至 28 岁、正在与创伤、抑郁、焦虑以及其他情绪、人格和共病问题做斗争的青少年和年轻人提供注重结果的精神健康护理。在 Newport Healthcare，量身定制的治疗方案可促进可持续的康复，帮助年轻人从挣扎走向蓬勃发展。了解更多信息请访问 newporthealthcare.com。过去几年里，数字技术呈爆发式增长，它们承诺帮助人们实现健康和健身目标。有追踪饮食和体重的应用程序，有计算步数的，还有定制锻炼日常的。2020 年的一份市场研究报告发现，全球健康与健身应用市场目前的价值已达 13 亿美元，并预测到 2030 年其价值将超过 40 亿美元。这些应用程序或许在商业上取得了成功，但它们是实用的公共卫生工具吗？
As the world confronts what public health organizations have called an obesity epidemic, what role might digital interventions play in combating it? Do these apps work? Do they help people adopt healthier habits? Or, conversely, might they contribute to the mental health toll that weight stigma can take in a culture that's obsessed with thinness? If you want to try using health and fitness apps, how can you find ones that are effective? effective, helpful, and backed by research. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association
当世界正面临公共卫生组织所谓的肥胖流行时，数字干预措施能在与之抗争中发挥什么作用？这些应用真的管用吗？它们能帮助人们养成更健康的习惯吗？或者相反，在一个痴迷于纤瘦的文化中，体重污名化会带来精神健康代价，而这些应用是否会助长这种代价？如果你想尝试使用健康与健身应用，如何才能找到那些真正有效、有帮助且有研究支持的应用？欢迎收看《心理学热线》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学学会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，
that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Gary Bennett. Dr. Bennett is a clinical health psychologist and professor of psychology and neuroscience, global health and medicine at Duke University, where he is also vice provost for undergraduate education. He is the founding director of the Duke Global Digital Health Science Center, where his research focuses on designing, testing, and disseminating digital treatments for obesity and other chronic health conditions, particularly for medically vulnerable patients.
旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是加里·贝内特博士（Dr. Gary Bennett）。贝内特博士是一位临床健康心理学家，也是杜克大学心理学与神经科学、全球健康与医学教授，他还在该校担任负责本科生教育的副教务长。他是杜克全球数字健康科学中心（Duke Global Digital Health Science Center）的创办主任，该中心的研究重点是设计、测试和推广针对肥胖及其他慢性健康状况的数字疗法，特别是针对医疗弱势患者群体。
Dr. Bennett is a past president of the Society of Behavioral Medicine and has authored more than 150 scientific papers. His research has been featured in the New York Times, NPR, Time, and many other media outlets. He has also founded three digital health startups, and advises digital health and consumer electronic organizations on the science of health behavior change. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Bennett. What pleasure is mine. Thanks so much for the invitation.
贝内特博士是行为医学会（Society of Behavioral Medicine）的前任会长，撰写了 150 多篇科学论文。他的研究曾在《纽约时报》、美国国家公共电台（NPR）、《时代》杂志以及许多其他媒体上报道。他还创立了三家数字健康初创公司，并就健康行为改变的科学向数字健康和消费电子组织提供咨询。非常感谢您今天能做客我们的节目，贝内特博士。这实在是我的荣幸。非常感谢您的邀请。
Let's start with a definition, as we often do on this podcast. Many of us are familiar with some commercial health and fitness apps. You know, we've probably seen ads for NUM or downloaded things like My Fitness Pal. Is that what you're looking at when you study digital health interventions? How broad is the category and what do you consider a real digital health intervention? Indeed. And we've all been inundated with advertisements and of all types for these digital apps. And that is what we study.
让我们从一个定义开始，正如我们在这个播客中经常做的那样。我们许多人都熟悉一些商业健康和健身应用。你知道的，我们可能看过 Noom 的广告，或者下载过像 MyFitnessPal 这样的软件。这正是你在研究数字健康干预时所关注的内容吗？这个类别的范围有多广？你认为真正的数字健康干预是什么？确实如此。而且我们所有人都被各种各样的这些数字应用广告狂轰滥炸过。这正是我们所研究的内容。
So we're very interested in the effectiveness of the digital apps that, again, so many of us are using to manage our weight and improve our physical activity to help with our sleep. We are trying to create these in a laboratory setting. in a way that we hope will make them maximally effective. And the apps that we create in the scientific community look and feel and behave a little bit differently than what you see in the commercial realm. And I hope we can get to a conversation about that. They're a little bit different. But fundamentally, we're just trying to help people improve their health in an easy, accessible way using the tools that they tend to use all day, every day anyway. So much of your research is focused on digital interventions for obesity, how well do these work and what makes them effective?
因此，我们对我们当中有那么多人正在使用的、用于管理体重、改善体育活动以及帮助睡眠的数字应用的效果非常感兴趣。我们正试图在实验室环境中以一种我们希望使其效果最大化的方式来创建这些应用。我们在科学界创建的应用，其外观、感觉和行为表现与你在商业领域看到的略有不同。我希望我们能就此展开讨论。它们确实有点不同。但从根本上说，我们只是试图使用人们无论如何都会全天候使用的工具，以一种简单、易用的方式帮助人们改善健康。你的许多研究都集中在针对肥胖的数字干预上，这些干预的效果如何？是什么让它们发挥作用？
There are two answers to that question. So let's for a moment just focus on what we know about the kinds of apps that so many people are downloading onto their phones. These are the apps that you can go to the app store of various types and download and use today, the ones that are in the commercial space. The short answer is we know very little about whether and how they work, how well they work. We especially know very little about how well they work relative to one another and how well they work relative to established treatments that we know work very well. So if you were to go to your doctor and go to a weight loss group perhaps in your local community that's based on strong weight loss. loss science, we have a good sense of how well they work, particularly over the long time horizon that is necessary for people to have durable and kind of persistent weight losses. We don't really know how well apps work relative to those kinds of treatments. And in fact, much of what we've learned
对这个问题的回答有两个部分。所以让我们先花一点时间关注我们所了解的那类许多人正在下载到手机上的应用。这些是你可以通过各种应用商店下载并在今天就开始使用的应用，也就是商业领域中的应用。简短的回答是，我们对它们是否以及如何发挥作用、效果如何知之甚少。我们尤其知之甚少的是，它们彼此相比效果如何，以及与我们已知非常有效的既定治疗方法相比效果如何。因此，如果你去看医生，或者参加当地社区基于强有力减重科学的减重小组，我们对它们的效果有很好的了解，特别是对于人们实现持久和持续减重所必需的长期时间范围而言。我们并不真正清楚应用与这些类型的治疗相比效果如何。事实上，我们迄今所学到的很多东西
thus far suggests that they work minimally and not as well as we might like and certainly not as well as do those very established treatments. So then there's the second. answer that question is, how well do the apps work that we're testing in the research world? So for me and my colleagues who do digital health science, we're creating apps all the time and broad digital treatments that incorporate lots of different components. They look and feel quite a lot like what you could download in the app store. But generally speaking, you can't download them in the app store. These are things that we're testing in the lab. Those treatments, they work pretty well. Generally speaking, we see that people can lose
都表明，它们的效果微乎其微，不如我们所希望的那样好，当然也比不上那些非常既定的治疗方法。那么这就有了对该问题的第二个回答：我们在研究世界中测试的应用效果如何？因此，对于我和从事数字健康科学的同事们来说，我们一直在创建应用以及包含许多不同组件的广泛数字疗法。它们的视觉和触觉体验与你在应用商店里下载的东西非常相似。但通常来说，你无法在应用商店里下载它们。这些是我们在实验室中测试的东西。那些疗法效果相当不错。总体而言，我们发现人们可以减掉
somewhere between, call it seven, eight pounds of weight at about six months, which for us is a pretty good outcome. That's really the ceiling, though. There's a lot of that. That is like, that's about the most amount of weight you're going to lose with one of these digital labs. There's a lot of variability in how much weight people lose. And so one of the things that's really important in this conversation is that those of us who do the science of obesity treatment think very differently about weight loss than do many folks in the public. We're fundamentally interested in producing weight losses that will help people improve their health generally, and then more specifically help to improve things like blood pressure, glucose, lipids, like your cholesterol,
大约 7 到 8 磅的体重，大约在六个月的时间里，对我们来说这是一个相当不错的成果。不过，这确实是上限。这大致就是你通过这些数字应用能够减掉的最大体重了。人们减掉的体重差异很大。因此，这次对话中非常重要的一点是，我们这些从事肥胖治疗科学研究的人，对减重的看法与公众中的许多人有很大不同。我们根本上感兴趣的是产生有助于人们全面改善健康的减重效果，更具体地说，是帮助改善血压、血糖、血脂（如胆固醇）等指标，
those kinds of things. And frankly, you don't need to lose a whole lot of weight to see major improvements in those kinds of outcomes in your blood pressure and glucose in your cholesterol, all, your triglycerides. We're not generally as interested in the large amount of weight loss that so many people want in order to kind of go on the beach in the summer or get ready for wedding or those kinds of things. What we know, generally speaking, is that most apps that you can download today don't deliver those kinds of weight losses. So what makes an app work for people? Why do the ones that you're using in the lab work more effectively than something that I might just arbitrarily go by in the app store? Well, one of the reasons is,
诸如此类的事情。坦率地说，你不需要减掉太多的体重，就能看到你的血压、血糖、胆固醇以及甘油三酯等指标发生重大改善。通常情况下，我们并不那么关注许多人为了夏天去海滩、准备婚礼或类似事情而想要减掉的大量体重。我们普遍知道的是，今天你能下载的大多数应用都无法带来那种程度的体重减重。那么，究竟是什么让一个应用对人们起作用呢？为什么你在实验室里使用的应用比我可能在应用商店里随便买的某种东西更有效？嗯，原因之一在于，
is that we're basing the apps in the scientific community on literally, you know, a generation or two of a research about what contributes to successful weight loss. And generally speaking, what makes an app work in the scientific world are the kinds of components that you should be looking for in the apps that you download commercially. And so those components would be things like self-monitoring or tracking. If an app isn't asking you to try, you to try, track what you're eating or what you're drinking or really something, something you can stick with. We've done a lot of work in tracking one's weight. Then it's not going to work.
我们在科学界开发的应用程序，字面意思上是建立在对成功减重因素的一两代人的研究基础之上的。总的来说，让应用程序在科学世界中发挥作用的各种组件，也是你在商业下载的应用程序中应该寻找的组件。因此，这些组件将包括自我监测或追踪。如果一个应用程序没有要求你尝试追踪你吃的东西、喝的东西，或者确实是某种你能坚持下去的东西——我们在追踪体重方面做了大量的工作——那么它就不会起作用。
One of the things we know the most about is that you have to track something. And we can talk a bit more if you're interested about why this works, but you have to track something. The second thing is the app has to teach you skills. It has to teach you how to manage your calorie consumption, your food consumption, what you're drinking, your physical activity, particularly during times when you're stressed or when you're around other people. It has to teach you how to engage with your food in a way that helps you to be able to maximize your weight loss. There's a whole realm of skills that we know work.
我们最清楚的事项之一就是，你必须追踪某些东西。如果你感兴趣的话，我们可以多聊聊为什么这管用，但你必须追踪某些东西。第二点是，应用程序必须教给你技能。它必须教你如何管理你的卡路里消耗、食物消耗、你喝的东西、你的体育活动，特别是在你感到压力时，或者当你和别人在一起的时候。它必须教你如何以一种有助于你最大程度减重的方式来与你的食物互动。我们知道有一整套技能是切实管用的。
And the app has to teach you that. The third thing that we know really works well is support. And this is one of the most counterintuitive things about the digital space. almost all apps that work very well for weight loss include some type of support. And that support's often delivered by a human counselor. Sometimes it's via chat. Sometimes it's via phone. Sometimes it's in person.
并且应用程序必须教给你这些。我们知道确实效果很好的第三件事是支持。这是数字领域中最违反直觉的事情之一。几乎所有对减重非常有效的应用程序都包含某种类型的支持。而且这种支持通常由人类顾问提供。有时是通过聊天。有时是通过电话。有时是面对面的。
But apps that don't include support of some type generally have much smaller outcomes than apps do that include support. And you have to modify something. You have to eat less, move more. We can have lots of debates about the specific diets that apps recommend. And generally speaking, I'm not a fan of any particular diet. Science pretty strongly suggests you should just do something you can stick with. But if you download an app that says, you know, you don't have to track something, you don't have to change what you're eating and drinking, then you're not going to see weight losses.
但是不包含某种支持的应用程序，其效果通常比包含支持的应用程序要小得多。你必须做出改变。你必须少吃多动。关于应用程序推荐的具体饮食，我们可以有很多争论。总的来说，我不赞成任何特定的饮食。科学强烈表明，你只需要做一些你能坚持下去的事情。但如果你下载了一个应用程序，上面写着“你知道的，你不需要追踪任何东西，你不需要改变你的饮食和饮酒习惯”，那么你就不会看到体重减轻。
Okay? It's actually not more complicated than that. So in the scientific community, our apps do all of those things. And when you're looking for an app that you can download from your app store, you want to also be looking for those things. So an app that sends electronic messages of encouragement or reminders, right? That's not the same as human intervention. Does that matter? And my other question is, are people more motivated if they are actually paying for an app? So on the first point, yes, getting reminders, getting a little bit of support, a little reinforcement, a little pat on the back, those are tremendous.
好吧？其实事情并不比这更复杂。因此，在科学界，我们的应用程序能做到所有这些事情。当你在寻找可以从应用商店下载的应用程序时，你也应该寻找这些功能。那么，一个发送鼓励电子消息或提醒的应用程序，对吧？这与人类干预是不同的。这重要吗？我的另一个问题是，如果人们实际上为应用程序付费，他们的积极性会更高吗？关于第一点，是的，获得提醒、得到一点支持、一点强化、一点认可，这些都非常棒。
And you absolutely should be looking for that in your app. That's a little different than the kind of support I'm talking about, though. So the support that really works well is support that's of the type that helps you to problem solve. Like when you're having a difficult time, you know, when you're going out with colleagues or with friends, and you're trying to figure out how you're going to approach eating that evening, you know, having someone to talk to and talk through that. When you've had a slip or slide, you've consumed more than you wanted to on the weekend, like the, you know, We played a nachos I had last weekend. You want somebody to try to talk to help manage that, those kinds of situations.
你绝对应该在你的应用中寻找这些。不过，这与我所说的那种支持有点不同。因此，真正发挥良好作用的支持是那种能帮你解决问题的支持。比如，当你经历困难时期时，你知道的，当你和同事或朋友外出，正在琢磨那天晚上该怎么对待饮食时，有个可以倾诉并一起探讨的人。当你滑倒或退步时，比如你在周末摄入了比预期更多的东西——就像我上周末吃的纳乔斯玉米片（nachos）一样——你需要有人来交谈，以帮助管理那种状况，应对那些情况。
That kind of support is really the kind of gold standard support that leads to the largest weight losses. And, you know, the second question you asked Kim about, if you're paying for an app, we stick with it longer. The answer is yes. And that gets to a really fundamental challenge for those of us who are designed these kinds of apps. At the end of the day, what really matters for long-term weight loss is not what you're doing. doing today or tomorrow in the app. It's what you're doing six months, seven months down the road with the app. Weight loss is a long-term game. And we're often thinking about a psychologist is how do we motivate you to stay involved, to stay engaged with these kinds of digital
这种支持确实是能够带来最大减重效果的黄金标准支持。而且，金，你问的第二个问题，如果你为应用付费，我们会坚持更久吗？答案是肯定的。这就触及了我们这些设计此类应用的人所面临的一个根本挑战。归根结底，对长期减重真正重要的不是你今天或明天在应用里做什么。而是你六个月、七个月后如何使用这个应用。减重是一场持久战。作为心理学家，我们经常思考的是，如何激励你保持参与，在减肥并保持体重所需的长期时间里，持续使用这些数字疗法。
treatments for the long time horizon that it takes to be able to lose weight and keep it off. And so anything that we can do to keep you engaged is really critical. And paying for apps seems to be helpful in keeping you engaged. So it's not, you know, it works by through that engagement function that's just so important. But at the end of the day, what we find in all the studies that have looked at this question is whether you're paying for the app or you're not paying for the app, whether you're using a science-based app or one that comes off the app store, is that people have declining engagement.
因此，我们能做的任何能让你保持参与的事情都至关重要。付费购买应用似乎有助于让你保持参与。所以它之所以起作用，是通过那种非常重要的参与功能来实现的。但归根结底，所有研究过这一问题的研究所发现的是，无论你是否为应用付费，无论你使用的是基于科学的应用还是应用商店下载的应用，人们的参与度都在下降。随着时间的推移，坚持使用这些应用变得越来越难。这正是我们许多人目前正在纠结的真正重要的科学问题。那些让你输入目标的应用程序怎么样？比如减重目标。所以可能你体重 150 磅，然后你输入你想减到 110 磅。你知道，这太疯狂了吗？这能帮到人们，还是比什么都更让人灰心？拥有一个减重目标至关重要。这是第一个回答。
Over time, it just gets harder and harder to stick with these apps. And that's the really important scientific question that so many of us are struggling with right now. What about the apps that make you put in a goal, a weight loss goal? And so maybe you weigh 150 pounds and you put in that you want to weigh 110. You know, is that crazy? Does that help people or is that more discouraging than anything else? It's critically important to have a weight loss goal. So that's first answer.
不过，这的第二部分是，拥有一个可实现的减重目标至关重要。所以，你知道的，有时对于其中一些不针对你的减重目标给予反馈的应用，我会有点担忧。你知道的，你体重 150 磅，然后输入 100 磅。你打算在三个月内减掉 100 磅。这是不可能的，或者说，这可能吗？我们很聪明。当然一点都不聪明。
Second part of that is, though, it's critically important to have an achievable weight loss goal. So, you know, sometimes with some of these apps that don't give you feedback about your weight loss goal, I get a little bit concerned. You know, you're 150 pounds and you put in 100 pounds. You're going to lose 100 pounds in three months. That's not possible or, you know, it's possible. We're smart. Certainly not smart.
你不会想那样做的。我向你保证。我们通常认为安全的减重数量是你当前体重的 5% 到 10% 之间。总的来说，另一种思考方式是，每周减重大约 1 到 2 磅是安全的。如果你减得比这快得多，就会让自己陷入不安全的境地，同时也可能让自己陷入不可持续的境地。减掉大量体重的人有反弹的倾向。所以我们要追求的是一种缓慢而稳定的减重。
You don't want to do that. I can promise. We generally think that a safe amount of weight loss is somewhere between 5 to 10% of your body weight today. And generally, the other way to think about this is it's safe to lose about a pound to two a week. You don't, if you lose much more rapidly than that, it can, you can put yourself in an unsafe situation, but you can also put yourself in an unsustainable situation. People who lose massive amounts of weight rapidly have a tendency to gain it back. So it's a kind of slow and steady amount of
是的，绝对地，如果你使用的应用不允许你输入减重目标，或者它不给你设定减重目标，你应该寻找具备这一功能的应用。因此，体重和肥胖是复杂的话题。我的意思是，它们是一个健康问题，但在人们如何看待体重的背后，还包裹着远超健康本身的许多东西。近年来，在像我们这样痴迷于纤瘦的文化中，关于体重污名化所带来的代价，已经有很多讨论。你是否担心其中一些减重应用实际上是在加剧这个问题，因为它们助长了对体重的关注，而这可能会对人们的精神和身体健康造成危害？是的，我担心。我得说，我更担心
weight loss is what we're going after. And yeah, absolutely, if you use an app that doesn't have, allow you to put a weight loss goal or it doesn't give you a weight loss goal, you should look for one that has that feature. So weight and obesity are complicated topics. I mean, they're a health issue, but there's a lot more than health wrapped up in how people think about weight. And in recent years, has been a lot of discussion about the toll that weight stigma can take in a culture that's obsessed with thinness as ours is. Are you concerned that some of these weight loss apps are actually adding to the problem by contributing to a focus on weight that could be harmful to people's mental and physical health? Yeah, I am. I'll say I'm more concerned
体重污名化的社会挑战。这是一个普遍存在的公共卫生挑战。我真的认为这对我们来说是一个公共卫生挑战，尤其是考虑到我们国家很高的肥胖率，以及体重污名化如此规范化、人们如此频繁地经历体重污名化，这是一个重大关切。而且，你知道的，我的实验室里现在有一个学生克里斯蒂娜·霍普金斯（Christina Hopkins），我认为她正在就这个问题做一些非常重要、具有突破性的工作。她发现，经历体重污名化无疑会使减重变得更加困难。毫无疑问。但它会造成巨大的情感代价。它会影响你的心血管系统。它会升高你的血压，就像我们知道的其他类型的歧视性压力会影响身体一样。
about the societal challenge of weight stigma. And it's a pervasive public health challenge. And I really do think it is a public health challenge for us, especially given the high rates of obesity that we have in this country, the fact that weight stigma is so normalized and so frequently experienced by people is a major concern. And, you know, I have a student right now in my lab, Christina Hopkins, who's doing some really important groundbreaking work, I think, on this question. and what she finds is that experiencing weight stigma makes it harder for sure to lose weight. There's no question about that. But it exacts a significant emotional toll. It can affect your cardiovascular system. It can raise your blood pressure in the same way that we know other types of discriminatory stress can affect the body.
这是一个重大挑战。因此，我确实担心，通过应用获取治疗的便利性可能会给某些人带来一些具有挑战性的结果。但再次强调，我认为体重污名化的社会挑战才是真正更大的问题。这是我们真正需要去应对的事情。当我谈论肥胖时，当业内大多数人谈论肥胖时，我们真的认为这是一种健康状况，是许多慢性疾病（心血管疾病、糖尿病、癌症）的根本原因。这是一个风险因素，如果我们能解决它，我们真的能在改善人们健康方面做很多事情。
It's a major challenge. And so I am concerned that the ease of accessing treatments via. app can for some people lead to some challenging outcomes. But again, I think the societal challenge of weight stigma is really the bigger problem. It's the thing that we really, that we need to contend with. When I talk about obesity and when most of us in the business talk about obesity, we really think of this as a health condition, as a root cause of so many chronic illnesses, cardiovascular disease, diabetes, cancer. It is a risk factor that if we can address, us, we can really do a lot to improve people's health.
在过去的五年里，我可以说，我们所有人都一直在纠结如何以一种既能最大限度地关注与其相关的健康挑战、又能将我们可能强加给患者的污名化降到最低的方式来谈论肥胖和减重。因此，除了肥胖之外，你一直在研究针对其他慢性健康状况的数字干预措施，你刚才也提到了其中一些，还有哪些其他健康状况可以被绝对有效地解决？这些是人们可以自己做的事情吗？比如，你如何自己追踪胆固醇？是的，有充分的证据表明我们可以通过应用帮助人们管理血压。
And in Creever, the last five years, I would say, all of us are struggling with how to talk about obesity and weight loss in a way that maximizes our attention to its health challenges associated with it and minimizes the kind of stigma that we might be placing on our patients. So you've been studying digital interventions for other chronic health conditions in addition to obesity and you just mentioned a few of them, what other health conditions can absolutely effectively address? And are these things that people can do on their own? Like, how do you track your own cholesterol, for example? Yeah, there's good evidence that we can help people to manage their blood pressure using
特别是对于患有高血压的人来说，几年前高血压的定义和高血压治疗指南发生了变化。一夜之间，我的意思是，字面上有数百万美国人被诊断出患有高血压，这是因为高血压指南被调低了一点。对于处于极低水平的新发高血压诊断，一线治疗是改变饮食和体育活动。这些是我们知道有效的事情。因此，许多现有的帮助你改变饮食和体育活动的减重应用，对于这些慢性病也很有用。特别是对于高血压和糖尿病，我们知道，防止从我们过去所称的
apps. Particularly for folks who have hypertension, there was a change made in the definitions of hypertension and the guidelines for hypertension treatment a couple of years ago. And overnight, I mean, literally millions of Americans developed a hypertension diagnosis is because the hypertension guidelines were reset a little bit lower. And the first line treatment for a new hypertension diagnosis at a very low level is changing your diet and your physical activity. These are things that we know work. So a lot of the existing weight loss apps that help you to change your diet physical activity can also be useful for these chronic conditions. And particularly hypertension and diabetes, we know that one of the best strategies to prevent the transition from what we used to call.
糖尿病前期（非常非常低水平的糖尿病）转变为成熟的 2 型糖尿病的最佳策略之一，其实是改变饮食、增加体育活动，并减掉大约 7% 的体重。因此，单单专注于改变饮食和改善体育活动，就能带来一系列益处。确实有专门用于管理胆固醇、管理血压、管理糖化血红蛋白（A1C）的定制应用程序。但在大多数情况下，我会说许多减重应用程序实际上在改变和帮助我们修改这些条件的风险因素、
pre-diabetes, very, very low levels of diabetes to full-blown type 2 diabetes is actually changing your diet, your physical activity, and losing about 7% of your body weight. So there's a way in which just focusing on changing your diet and improving your physical activity can have a range of benefits. There are definitely bespoke apps for managing your cholesterol managing, your blood pressure managing your A1C. But for the most part, I'd say a lot of the weight loss actually. actually do a really good job of modifying, helping us to modify the risk factors for those
并帮助许多患者自我管理他们的病情方面，做得非常出色。你刚才提到了自我管理，但数字干预措施如何融入更大的医疗保健图景中？它们是人们应该在咨询医生的情况下使用的东西，还是应该自己使用，或者两者兼而有之？在过去的几年里，我对此问题的回答发生了很大变化，特别是对于肥胖治疗而言。而且，你知道的，很长一段时间以来，我们建议患者与医生讨论他们的肥胖问题，但证据相当清楚，许多患有肥胖症的患者并未在初级保健机构中获得针对肥胖的治疗
conditions and helping a lot of patients to self-manage their conditions. So you just mentioned self-management, but how do digital interventions fit into the larger healthcare picture? Are they something that people should be using in consultation with their physician or use on their own or a little of both? My answer to this question has shifted a lot over the last couple of years. particularly for obesity treatment. And, you know, for a long time, we suggested that patients talk to their doctor about their obesity, but the evidence was pretty clear that a lot of patients with obesity weren't receiving treatment
或关于体重的咨询。这背后有充分的理由。这是一项非常耗时、耗费专业知识且类似的工作，大多数医生并未接受过相应的培训，或者感觉不舒服去做。没有得到报酬去做，也没有时间去做。因此，在很长一段时间里，我原以为——事实上，我开始做大量这类工作的原因之一就是——帮助提供一种额外的治疗策略，
for their obesity or counseling about their weight in the primary care setting. And there's good reasons for that. It's a very time intensive and expertise intensive and kind of undertaking that most physicians weren't trained to do or don't feel comfortable doing. weren't reimbursed to do, didn't have the time to do. And so for a long time, I thought, I mean, a lot, in fact, one of the reasons I started doing a lot of this work was to help to provide an additional treatment strategy
这可能会帮助医生将肥胖治疗分流给应用程序。这样他们就不必在治疗过程中亲自去做了。但在过去的几年里，我们意识到（包括我们团队开展的一些研究），这非常清楚地表明，当你的医生知道这种治疗方法，知道你用来管理体重的应用程序时。当那位医生给予你强化、指导、确认以及对你使用这些应用程序的认可时，
that might help physicians to offload the obesity treatment to the act. So it's something that they didn't have to do in the course of their treatment. But in the last couple of years, what we've realized, including some studies that have come out of our group, it shows pretty clearly that when your physician, when your physician knows about the treatment, the app that you're using to manage your weight. And when that physician gives you reinforcement, guidance, validation, pat on the back for
你实际上会减掉更多体重。这是一个非常简单的道理。我们很多人对自己的医生都非常有责任感。我们很多人都会向医生咨询，以确保我们在做正确的事情。当那位医生觉得这个应用程序适合你使用，并且它能给你提供良好的指导和肯定时，我们往往会做得更好一点。我们往往会有更多的动力，更能够坚持和参与这些应用程序。所以我现在的强烈建议是，如果你试图通过使用应用程序来减肥，
using those apps, you actually lose more weight. And it's a pretty straightforward story. A lot of us feel very accountable to our physicians. A lot of us check in with our physicians to make sure we're doing the right thing. And when that physician feels like the app is the right thing for you to use and it's giving you good guidance and good validation, we tend to do a little bit better. we tend to be a bit more motivated and a little bit more adhere and engage with those apps. So my strong suggestion these days is that if you're trying to use to lose way of using an app,
让你的医生知道，让他们知道你在用什么应用程序，让他们知道你是如何使用该应用程序的，并让他们参与到这个过程中。我猜这可能会带来一些好处。当然也绝对不会有什么坏处。本期节目由 Newport Healthcare 赞助，致力于为面临精神健康问题的年轻人提供可持续的康复，帮助他们从自我毁灭走向自尊，以同情心为基础，以结果为导向。Newport 在全国的住宅和门诊项目中服务于 12 至 28 岁的青少年和年轻人。
let your physician know, let them know what app you're using, let them know how you're using the app and get them involved in that process. And I suspect it may have some benefits. It certainly can't hurt. Sponsored by Newport Healthcare, dedicated to providing sustainable healing for young people struggling with mental health concerns so they can move. from self-destruction to self-esteem, based in compassion and driven by outcomes. Newport serves teens and young adults ages 12 to 28 at residential and outpatient programs
通过量身定制的治疗和家庭支持，Newport 成功解决心理和行为健康问题，包括抑郁、焦虑、PTSD、人格障碍和药物滥用。了解更多信息请访问 Newport Healthcare.com。对于我们中一些可能想尝试这些应用程序的听众来说，他们如何找到那些有效的应用程序？或者他们甚至可能想使用你正在开发的应用程序？现在有什么你们正在做、人们可以加入的研究吗？是的。
nationwide. Through tailored treatment and family support, Newport successfully addresses psychological and behavioral health issues, including depression, anxiety, PTSD, personality disorders, and substance abuse. Learn more at Newport Healthcare.com. For some of our listeners who maybe want to try some of these apps, how do they find the ones that are effective? Or maybe they even want to use the apps that you're developing? Are there studies that you're doing right now that people could enroll in? Yes.
所以我想说，在商业领域，要做的就是，你知道的，目前广泛使用的许多应用程序并没有坚实的证据基础，这意味着没有大量研究试验证明它们有效。所以再次强调，我认为你需要寻找这些东西：自我监测、支持、技能培训以及这些类型的问题。并且选择一款你能坚持下去的应用程序。因此，在所有肥胖治疗中最重要的事情之一，无论你谈论的是你采用的具体饮食还是你正在使用的应用程序，其核心都在于
So I'd say, you know, in the commercial space, the thing to do is, you know, get money of the apps that are widely available right now don't have a strong evidentiary basis, meaning there's not a lot of research trials that show that they work. So again, I think you want to look for those things and self-monitoring, support, the skills training, those kinds of those issues. And down on the app that you can stick with. So one of the most important things in all of obesity treatment, whether you're talking about the specific diet that you're adopting or the app that you're using, it's all about
能够在很长一段时间内保持持续的参与。有些应用程序就是这样。我喜欢，我只是更喜欢它们的外观，对吧？比如，我喜欢颜色。我喜欢弹出来的小东西。它们更容易使用。选择一个你能长期坚持使用的应用程序。理想情况下，你会选择一个背后有一点证据支持的应用程序。
can being consistently engaged over an extended period of time. There are just some apps. I like, I just like the way they look better, right? Like, I like the colors. I like the little things that pop up. They are easier to use. Get the app that you can stick with for a long-term time, for the long-time horizon. Ideally, you would pick an app that has a little bit of evidence behind it.
我认为这个领域的许多公司在随着证据的出现而分享这些证据方面做得越来越好。我会确保你选择的应用程序具有坚实的证据基础。我们绝对一直在做试验。并且我可以，也许我们可以把我们的网站放在备注里。任何对我们的工作感兴趣的人都欢迎联系我们并参与进来。好的，我们一定会这么做。因此，使用这些应用程序的人必须交出相当大一部分个人信息，
And I think a lot of companies in this space are getting better about sharing that evidence as it becomes available. And I would make sure that you're picking apps that have a strong evidence basis. We are absolutely doing trials all the time. And I can, maybe we can put our website in the notes. And anybody out there who's interested in our work is welcome to contact us and get involved. Okay, we will definitely do that. So people who are using these apps have to give up a fair amount of personal information
而隐私在目前的科技领域是一个备受关注的问题，理应如此。如果人们想尝试这些应用程序，但又担心交出太多敏感信息，他们能做些什么呢？是的，这是一个顽固的挑战。在我从事这项工作的 20 年里，我们一直没能彻底解决这个问题。而且，在患者层面、用户层面，要驾驭所有这些各种各样的服务条款、条款和条件以及隐私挑战，变得越来越具有挑战性。我想说，我对此的一般经验法则是，下载一个应用程序，并虚构一个身份来评估该应用程序是否适合你，这完全是合理的。
and privacy is a concern in tech right now, as well it should be. What can people do if they want to try these apps but they're worried about giving up too much sensitive information? Yeah, this is just a pernicious challenge. We just haven't been able to nail this over the 20. years I've been doing this work. It's and it's gotten increasingly more challenging at the patient level, a user level to help navigate all the various terms and service and
这也是我所做的。每当出现一个全新的应用程序时。我都下载它，我使用它，而且我有大量不同版本的名字，这让我可以稍微隐藏一下自己。所以在那个领域你只能做到这些。你知道的，正如我之前指出的那样，最有效的应用程序是那些涉及支持的应用程序。因此，有一些非常强大的应用程序拥有优秀的用户社区，用户可以通过与其他用户交谈、或者与参与该应用程序的教练和顾问交谈来获得大量支持。
terms and conditions and privacy challenges here. I'd say my general rule of thumb on this is that it is it's totally reasonable to download an app and use and invent a persona in order to evaluate whether or not that app works for you. This is what I do. Every time there's a brand new app that comes on the scene. I download it, I use it, and I have no shortage of variations on my name that allow me to try to hide a little bit. So there's only so much you can do in that space.
我也经常建议人们在使用这类应用时使用假名之类的信息。参与其中确实会带来更好的结果。这是一件很重要的事情。但我很少用真名去做这件事。我认为情况变得最棘手的地方在于设备集成。我们开始看到各种各样的设备涌现出来，它们声称能帮你在体重上有所帮助，但也可以与许多这类应用链接。
You know, I think, as I noted before, the apps that work the best are those that have support involved. And so there are some very strong apps that have great user communities where someone can get a lot of support from talking to other users or talking to coaches and counselors that may be engaged in that apps. And I often recommend that people use fake names and things when you're using is in that as well. Getting involved actually does lead to better outcomes. It's an important thing to do. But I rarely do that using my real name. The area where I think this gets trickiest is in device integration. And we're starting to see a whole range of devices come on the scene that purport to help you with your way.
显然，我们长期以来都有体育活动监测设备，但现在它们在监测 GPS，对吧？我们有体重监测秤，它们做的事情远不止过去那样仅仅监测体重。当然，你知道，我们还看到持续血糖监测仪（CGM），有些人正在使用它，并将其与他们的减重应用连接起来。所以这真的是我认为事情变得有点棘手的地方。在这方面，关于设备集成，我的经验法则是明智行事：如果你担心隐私问题（并非每个人都担心，但如果你担心隐私），就要对是否真的需要将设备与
loss, but also can be linked with so many of these apps. Obviously, we've had physical activity monitoring devices for a long time, but now they're monitoring GPS, right? We have weight monitoring scales that are doing a whole lot more than they use than just monitoring your weight sometimes. And of course, you know, we're seeing continuous glucose monitors and that are that some folks are using and connecting with their weight loss apps as well. So that's really where I think things get a little trickier. And my rule of thumb there with respect to device integration is to be judicious about if you're concerned about privacy, and not everyone is, but if you're concerned about privacy, be judicious about whether you really need full integration of your devices with
这些应用进行完全集成保持审慎。我发现，通常你从设备本身就能获得一些反馈，这就足够好了。所以我经常不把设备连接到应用程序上，只是为了确保我的数据至少能够被防火墙隔离到不同的孤岛中。但再次强调，我意识到并不是每个人都关心这些事情。不幸的是，在这一点上，面临的挑战是，我们在这里做了很多联合，试图帮助你管理其中的一些隐私影响。你的研究中心被称为全球数字健康科学中心。我们来谈谈其中的“全球”部分。你认为数字干预在美洲以外的医疗保健中能发挥什么作用？你在其他国家做了多少工作？
those apps. I find that often you get a little feedback from the device itself, and that's good enough for me. And so I often don't connect the devices with the apps just to ensure that at least there's some firewalling of my data into different silos. But again, I recognize not everybody's concerned about those things. And at this point, unfortunately, the challenge, we're doing a lot of confederation here to try to help you manage some of those privacy implications. Your research center is called the global digital health science center. Let's talk about the global part of that. What role do you see digital interventions playing in health care outside the U.S. and how much work are you doing in other countries? Yeah, so it's actually the same answer I would give to, to, to the utility of digital to help us reach disadvantaged communities in this country, which, you know, we think about digital as one of the best strategies.
是的，实际上这与我对数字技术在帮助我们接触国内弱势群体方面的效用所给出的答案是一样的，你知道的，我们认为数字技术是最佳策略之一。在早期，我曾说它是最佳策略之一。现在，我认为它是帮助我们接触那些难以获得高质量医疗保健的人群的绝对最佳策略。目前对此几乎没有什么疑问。在早期，我们许多人都非常担心数字鸿沟。但现在，无论是在美国还是在全球各地的人群中，许多低收入人群、医学上脆弱的人群、地理上偏远的人群，都通过移动设备进行了非常显著的连接。
In the early days, I used to say it was one of the best strategies. Now, I think it is the very best strategy to help us reach populations that have difficulty accessing high-quality health care. I think there's very little question about that right now. In the early days, a lot of us were very concerned about the digital divide. But now, both in the U.S. and in populations around the world, many low-income populations folks that are medically vulnerable, geographically distant. They are connected through their mobile devices in a very significant way.
在某些方面、某些地方，包括在美国，通过移动设备，他们比我们的优势群体连接得更紧密。因此，这为我们提供了一个真正巨大的机会，去接触那些我们以前无法轻易接触的人，并通过这些数字手段提供高质量的护理。我们在中国开展过合作项目，也在非洲开展过合作项目。因此，我们对这些工具如何帮助我们跨越这些障碍非常感兴趣。高质量护理与更加
In some ways, sometimes in some places, including in the U.S., they're more connected than our more advantaged populations via their mobile devices. And so it just allows us a really tremendous opportunity to reach people we haven't been able to easily reach before and to deliver high-quality care through these digital means. We've done work in China and collaboratively, in Africa. And so we're very interested in how these tools might help us to traverse these. There's often the real and perceived distance between high quality care and patients in more
弱势社区的患者之间通常存在着真实和感知到的距离。而好消息是，至少在我们早期的经验中，我们的许多工具在全球这些情况下比在美国运行得更好，在许多情况下，它们在低收入人群中的表现比在高收入人群中更好。我知道这在某些方面让人感到困惑，但我认为在这方面证据相当有希望。因此，我无疑看到未来 10 年全球增长的巨大潜力。仅仅是因为美国人不喜欢别人告诉他们该做什么吗？
disadvantaged communities. And the good news, I think, at least in our early experience, is that a lot of our tools work a little better in these global circumstances than they do in the U.S., they work a little better in in lower income populations than they do in higher income populations in many cases. I know that feels confounding in some respects, but the evidence I think is pretty promising in that regard. So I see massive potential for growth globally over the next 10 years, for sure. Is that just because Americans don't like to be told what to do?
背后的原因是什么？你知道吗？对此无可奉告。但我要说的是，当你研究数字健康设备时，你会经常看到的一种现象是，人们倾向于非常非常频繁地更换他们的应用程序。所以，你知道的，他们会玩一会儿一个应用，然后下载下一个，再下载下一个，再下载下一个，评估下一个，对吧？我们看到了这一点，但在我们开展全球工作时，这种情况并没有那么普遍。
What's the reason for that? Do you know? No comment on that one. But I will say that when one of the things, one of the phenomena that you see a lot in these when you're studying digital health devices is that people tend to churn their apps very, very frequently. So, you know, they'll play with an app for a little while and they'll download the next one, they'll download the next one, we'll download the next one, we'll value the next one, right? And we see that, we don't see that quite as common when we're doing global work.
人们倾向于坚持使用这个应用程序。所以我们并不忠诚。我们稍微少了一点。稍微少了一点忠诚。我的意思是，这也是为什么，很长很长一段时间以来，你知道的，如果我在飞机上，有人问我做什么工作，然后，你知道的，我说我是个教授，他们会问，你教什么？然后我说，我们笑了笑。然后我说，我做数字健康研究。然后他们说，哦，所以，你知道的，这东西对老年人显然不管用。我通常会轻笑一声，因为这也相当、相当违反直觉。
People tend to stick on the app. So we're not loyal. We're a little bit less. little bit less loyal. I mean, this is one of the reasons why, you know, for a long, long time, people, if I'm on an airplane, somebody asks what I do, and, you know, I say I'm a professor, they say, what do you profess? And then I say, we laugh. And then I say, I do digital health research. And then they say, oh, so, you know, that obviously this stuff doesn't work in older folks. I usually chuckle a bit because that, too, is quite, quite counterintuitive.
人们往往会一直使用这个应用。所以我们并不忠诚。我们的忠诚度稍微差了一点，稍微差了一点。我的意思是，这也是为什么，你知道的，很长一段时间以来，人们，如果我在飞机上，有人问我是做什么的，你知道的，我说我是一名教授，他们会说，你教授什么？然后我说，我们笑了笑。接着我说，我从事数字健康研究。然后他们说，哦，所以，你知道的，显然这些东西在老年人身上没用。我通常会轻笑一声，因为这也相当、相当地与直觉相反。
Almost nothing, almost none of these digital approaches work among young people and among young adults. that there is very, very little evidence that we can produce health changes using apps in folks who are 20 to 40. Give me somebody who is north of 50, 55 any day in any of my trials and they're going to do a lot better. And a lot of it has to do with this. And when you're a digital native, you're just used to churning, right? You try something for a little while and then you throw it away and try the next thing. And as I mentioned before, so much of the promise of digital help depends on people being engaged with the app, actually using the thing. And what we find for folks who are a little bit older is they try it, they like it, they stick with it.
几乎没有，几乎没有任何这些数字方法在年轻人和年轻成年人中起作用。几乎没有证据表明，我们能通过针对20到40岁人群的应用程序带来健康状况的改变。随便给我一个50岁、55岁以上的人，在我任何一项试验中他们的表现都会好得多。这很大程度上与此有关。当你是一个数字原住民时，你只是习惯了不断尝试新事物，对吧？你尝试了一小会儿，然后把它扔掉，去尝试下一件。正如我之前提到的，数字健康的大部分前景取决于人们是否真正投入到应用程序中，并实际使用它。而我们发现，对于年纪稍大一点的人来说，他们会尝试、喜欢并坚持下去。
Now, this isn't something that you research directly, but I'm curious to hear your thoughts on mental health apps, since that's an area that's also received a lot of attention. And do you see a role for digital mental health interventions in addressing what some people are calling a mental health crisis? It is indeed a crisis, particularly among our young people. It's a pandemic on the order of others that we've experienced. It is the thing that literally in my administrative role at Duke would keep me and my colleagues up at night prior to the pandemic and the thing that I'm most concerned about as we come out of the pandemic. The Surgeon General has spoken very eloquently about this in recent years. And the truth is that we don't have great solutions right now. The mental health challenges, again, particularly facing young folks, but as is evidenced by the recent loss of Naomi judge really extends,
现在，这并不是你直接研究的课题，但我很好奇你对心理健康应用程序的看法，因为这也是一个受到广泛关注的领域。你认为数字心理健康干预措施在应对某些人所称的心理健康危机方面能发挥作用吗？这确实是一场危机，尤其是在我们的年轻人中。这是一场与其他我们经历过的疫情同等规模的大流行。在疫情爆发之前，这实际上是在杜克大学的行政管理岗位上让我和同事们夜不能寐的事情，也是我们在走出疫情时最关心的事。美国卫生总长近年来对此发表了非常精彩的讲话。事实是，我们目前还没有很好的解决方案。心理健康挑战，再次强调，尤其是年轻群体所面临的挑战，但正如娜奥米·贾德最近的离世所证明的那样，
extends throughout our population at all ages. It's just something we have a massive challenge with. We're unbelievably under-optimized in the number of mental health care providers in this country relative to the size of the challenge. And so for that reason, I am quite bullish on the potential of apps to help us meet the need of the broad swath of the American population who are dealing with lower levels of anxiety, depression, burnout, stress, feelings of sadness. For those kinds of, you know, what you could, we might call subclinical or just the kind
这种挑战蔓延到了我们各个年龄段的人群中。这只是我们面临的一个巨大挑战。相对于挑战的规模，我们这个国家的心理健康服务提供者数量严重不足。因此，出于这个原因，我非常看好应用程序的潜力，它们可以帮助我们满足广大美国民众的需求，这些人正在应对较低水平的焦虑、抑郁、职业倦怠、压力、悲伤情绪。对于这类，你知道的，你可以称之为亚临床的，或者仅仅是
of overarching feelings of sadness and burnout stress, those kinds of things, I think app-based approaches can be very, very useful as a first line offering as to kind of help give people a little bit of the skills and a little bit of the support to help them self-manage their way through some of those challenges. As people get into more serious levels of depression and anxiety, the kinds of clinical diagnoses that so many of us psychologists treat, I think we have less evidence in that space that the apps can work very well on their own to help people to manage their emotions. But I can tell you as a person who thinks about the mental health challenges facing a large number of young people in a university. I think absolutely have a role to play in helping us ensure that we can deliver the kind of skills training and support that would be just too difficult for us to do because we just frankly, none of us have enough counselors to be able to do that work well. Have you seen an uptick in interest over the past couple of years in your research, particularly because we have found from our polling during the COVID-19 pandemic is that a lot of us are gaining or losing weight that we didn't intend to?
那种普遍的悲伤、倦怠和压力，我认为基于应用程序的方法可以作为一线服务非常非常有用，能够帮助人们获得一些技能和支持，以帮助他们自我管理这些挑战。当人们陷入更严重的抑郁和焦虑，也就是我们许多心理学家治疗的那些临床诊断时，我认为我们在那个领域没有足够的证据证明应用程序可以很好地独立帮助人们管理情绪。但我可以告诉你，作为一个在大学里思考大量年轻人面临心理健康挑战的人，我认为它们绝对可以发挥作用，帮助我们确保能够提供技能培训和支持，如果我们自己去做会非常困难，因为坦白说，我们所有人都没有足够的咨询师来把这项工作做好。在过去的几年里，你的研究是否发现兴趣有所上升？特别是因为我们在COVID-19大流行期间通过民意调查发现，我们许多人的体重都在不知不觉中增加或减轻了？
Both are true. Goodness, yeah. People around here, I've often been telling me about their, you know, their pandemic weight or the, you know, their lockdown, lockdown gains and these things. And we have a little bit of evidence that that's true. The studies that have been tracking weight during the pandemic definitely show that people have been gaining. We've seen a retreat and the amount of physical activity that people are getting other types of problematic health behaviors. So yeah, we're seeing a lot of interest in digital health approaches in our trials. and a lot of interest in signing up. A lot of us have just gotten more comfortable using technology during the pandemic to manage all manner of aspects of our lives. And I think this is just another one of them. I'll tell you, the other thing that's happened in that regard that's been really useful is that the policy environment has changed a great deal during the pandemic. And so my vision for what digital health could represent as part of the healthcare system
两者都属实。天哪，是的。我周围的人经常跟我谈论他们的“大流行体重”或者居家隔离期间增加的体重之类的事情。我们有一些证据表明这是真的。在大流行期间追踪体重的研究绝对显示人们一直在发胖。我们看到人们的体力活动量有所下降，以及其他类型的有问题的健康行为。所以，是的，我们在试验中看到人们对数字健康方法有很大的兴趣，也有很多人踊跃报名。在大流行期间，我们许多人只是变得更加习惯于使用技术来管理生活的方方面面。我认为这只是其中又一个方面。我想告诉你，在这方面发生的另一件非常有用事情是，在疫情期间，政策环境发生了很大变化。因此，我对数字健康作为医疗系统一部分的愿景
has changed a lot in the last two years. I now really think that we have the ability to very widely implement digital strategies as part of, as part of our health system. To date, a lot of the digital health apps have really been like part of consumer health, consumer electronics companies. It's like been things that you download from companies that aren't necessarily associated with where you go to get your health care. And that's changing very, very rapidly. And it's, you know, if there's a, if there's any silver lining in the pandemic, I think that that's one. Are you seeing big health care providers then trying to develop or partner with people like you who are developing evidence-based apps? Like, could I go to Kaiser Permanente where I have my insurance and, you know, get some apps?
在过去两年中发生了很大变化。我现在真的认为我们有能力将数字策略作为我们卫生系统的一部分进行广泛实施。迄今为止，许多数字健康应用程序实际上就像是消费者健康、消费电子公司的一部分。它们就像是你从那些不一定与你去看病的地方相关的公司下载的东西。这种情况正在非常非常迅速地改变。而且，你知道的，如果大流行有什么一线生机的话，我认为这就是其中之一。那么，你是否看到大型医疗机构试图开发或与像你这样开发循证应用程序的人合作？比如，我可以去我有保险的凯撒医疗集团（Kaiser Permanente），然后，你知道的，获取一些应用程序吗？
I haven't seen anything other than I think they've made calm available. Yeah. It's a very good point you make there, Kim, because I'm seeing two things happen. One is whenever a big health system decides it wants to do something new, they have this build versus. is buy challenge. Like, are we going to make it ourselves? Are we going to go out and do a deal where we can help to purchase it from somebody who's already doing it? And so what I'm seeing are that health systems are doing both of those things at the same time. We've been inundated with contacts from health systems that are interested in understanding more about what it would
除了他们让Calm变得可用之外，我没有看到其他任何事情。是的，凯姆。你提出的这一点非常好，吉姆，因为我看到两件事正在发生。一是每当一个大型医疗系统决定做一些新事情时，他们都会面临“自己构建还是购买”的挑战。比如，我们是要自己制作，还是去进行一笔交易，从一个已经在做这件事情的人那里购买？因此，我看到的是医疗系统同时在做这两件事。我们收到了大量医疗机构的联系，他们有兴趣更多地了解
take to build their own apps and services. And we're definitely seeing deals between most major health systems and existing providers to make these types of apps available to their patients. But they're rightfully struggling with the same thing that I mentioned at the beginning, which is, you know, your health system is for the first thing that they want to know is do these things work and how well do they work? It's the right question to ask. And so it's a, in my view, this is a, we're in a, we're in a very good time because for the health systems that are not getting the answers they want from commercial app providers, my hope is that those commercial app providers will do more research trials and find ways to improve the effectiveness of their
构建自己的应用程序和服务需要什么。我们绝对看到了大多数主要医疗系统与现有提供商之间的交易，以便向患者提供这些类型的应用程序。但他们也在苦苦挣扎，这与我一开始提到的一样，你知道的，你的医疗系统首先想知道的是这些东西是否管用，效果有多好？这是正确的问题。所以，在我看来，这是一个非常好的时期，对于那些没有从商业应用程序提供商那里得到想要答案的医疗系统，我希望这些商业应用程序提供商能够做更多的研究试验，并找到方法来提高其
apps. And my hope is that a lot of the big health systems will choose to work with folks who already have things sitting on the shelf that work pretty well. So I'm hoping that the landscape for high quality apps improves over the next couple of years. So what's next for you? What are you working on in your research lab? Well, two things. One is we're really interested in crack in this, what we call this engagement nut, which is, you know, what we say around the lab, lot is if you, generally speaking, if you use more, you lose more. And the real challenge in weight loss treatment isn't the diet. It isn't the physical activity prescription. It isn't which self-how you're going to self-monitor. It's not what skills to teach. It's how to keep
应用程序的有效性。我希望许多大型医疗系统会选择与那些手头已经有现成且效果相当不错的产品的机构合作。所以我希望高质量应用程序的市场在未来几年能够有所改善。那么你下一步的计划是什么？你在实验室里正在研究什么？嗯，两件事。一是我们真的很想攻克我们称之为“用户粘性”的难题，我们在实验室里经常说的一句话是：一般来说，你用得越多，你失去的就越多。而减肥治疗真正的挑战不是饮食。不是体力活动处方。不是你将如何进行自我监测。也不是要教什么技能。而是如何保持
people engaged over a long period of time. In a way that keeps them motivated, enhances their motivation, doesn't make them feel stigma or shame, really helps them to, it has a kind of whole person feel to it. So we're spending a lot of time now thinking, you know, what keeps people engaged in these kinds of treatments and how can we optimize our apps to help make it easier for people to stay engaged. And then the other thing we're working a lot on, and this is a little bit of a kind of a pointy-headed academic answer, but, you know, I'm a professor, so here you go. It's that, you know, for me, the fundamental, as I said before, the fundamental contradiction of all this thing, all this stuff is that almost all health apps work better when a human's involved.
人们在很长一段时间内的参与度。以一种能保持他们动力、增强他们动力、不让他们感到耻辱或羞耻、真正帮助他们、有一种全人关怀感觉的方式。所以我们现在花了很多时间在思考：是什么让人们持续参与这些治疗，以及我们如何优化我们的应用程序，以帮助人们更容易地保持参与度。我们要做的另一件事，这可能是一个有点迂腐的学术答案，但你知道的，我是一个教授，所以就这样吧。那就是，对我和我之前说过的一样，所有这些东西最根本的矛盾在于，几乎所有的健康应用程序在有真人参与时效果都更好。
You know, like, I've been, I've been programming from a very, very early age. I am not. very good at it, but I stick, I still play around. But I was a nerdy kid who was sitting around with my computer. I've been programming for a long, long time. And when I decided to step into the digital health space, I did so because I was trying to find a way to make the computers replicate the best of what I and other people do clinically. I was trying to get the humans out of the business. My thinking was that if you can design really high quality apps and take them to scale,
你知道的，我从很小的时候就开始编程了。我其实不怎么擅长，但我一直在坚持，我还在玩这个。但我是一个坐在电脑前的书呆子小孩。我编程已经有很长很长的时间了。当我决定涉足数字健康领域时，我这样做是因为我试图找到一种方法，让计算机复制我和其他人临床工作中的最佳表现。我试图让真人退出这个行业。我的想法是，如果你能设计出非常高质量的应用程序并将它们规模化，
then you can address large populations and not need a ton of me around, right? an easier, more effective way to get care, much less expensive. But the fact is that almost every study that we and my colleagues have ever done shows that the way that people use apps every day, we call it standalone. So I can just use in the app, doesn't have any human involvement. It just doesn't work as well as having a human involved. It's such a problem or such an issue that I often tell our clinical teams that apps and digital approaches tend to make humans do a better job in their care delivery. So like if I can if I can offload the more rote kind of parts of treatment to the app, then the humans can really do what humans do a great job at. And that is helping you to
那么你就可以服务大量的人群，而不需要周围有成吨的我，对吧？这是一种更简单、更有效、成本低得多的获取医疗服务的方式。但事实是，我和我的同事们做过的几乎每一项研究都表明，人们每天使用应用程序的方式，我们称之为“独立使用”（standalone）——也就是说我只能使用该应用程序，没有任何真人的参与——它的效果就是不如有真人参与。这是一个如此严重的问题或议题，以至于我经常对我们的临床团队说，应用程序和数字方法往往能让真人在医疗服务交付中做得更好。因此，如果我能将治疗中更常规的部分卸载给应用程序，那么人类就可以真正做好人类擅长的事情。那就是帮助你
problem solve, really making sure we're tailoring the treatment to you, giving you exactly what you need and not having to do all the other stuff that can be more easily deployed onto the app. So what we're trying to do right now is think about like how can we actually design apps that you, that can you be used by themselves with no humans involved? And can we do it in a way that actually make some work because right now they don't work so well. So that's the thing we're spending a lot of time thinking about. Huh. That's really interesting. Well, Dr. Bennett, thank you so much for joining me today. This has been really interesting. Oh, the pleasure's in mind. Kim. Thank you again. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.
解决问题，真正确保我们根据你的情况量身定制治疗方案，给你正是你所需要的东西，而不必去做那些可以更容易地部署到应用程序上的其他事情。所以我们现在正试图做的是思考：我们如何才能真正设计出可以由你自己使用、不需要任何人参与的应用程序？我们能否以一种真正让它们发挥作用的方式来做到这一点？因为目前它们的效果不是很好。这就是我们花很多时间思考的事情。哈。这真的很有趣。那么，班奈特博士，非常感谢你今天能来。这真的很有趣。哦，我的荣幸，吉姆。再次谢谢你。你可以在我们的网站上找到往期的《心理学谈话》节目，网址是www.
speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you hear, please leave us a review. If you have comments or for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
speakingofpsychology.org，或者在Apple、Stitcher或你获取播客的任何地方收听。如果你喜欢你听到的内容，请给我们留下评价。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或建议，你可以给我们发邮件至speakingofpsychology@APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·康迪汉（Chris Condihan）。谢谢收听。我是美国心理学协会的吉姆·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。